ah
la primera vez que escuché un comentario
como mamá las vacas pican o mamá las
gallinas muerden casi me infarto yo
tenía 5 años y no podía creer como un
niño de 9 podía pensar eso de crecer en
un rancho en querétaro junto con mis
papás con mis hermanas con mi agua y con
mi abuelo y ahí tuvimos un contacto
directo con la naturaleza y aprendimos
muchas cosas de ahí nació mi amor hacia
los seres vivos y en especial hacia los
animales
he tenido la fortuna de tener muchos
amigos animales que han dejado huella en
mi vida uno de estos amigos fue mi
hámster rayita rayita era un hámster
café que tenía una rayita blanca que se
portaba súper bien yo lo adoraba y un
día se me ocurrió llevar la rayita a la
escuela con mis compañeros para que
vieran qué bonito la rayita yo pensando
que a vallita les iba a encantar y cuál
va siendo mi sorpresa que no nada más no
les encantó sino que rayita les dio
mucho miedo no querían tocarlo no
querían acariciarlo no querían saber
nada de rayitas conforme fue pasando el
tiempo se dieron chance de sentirlo de
tocarlo de cargarlo y de darse cuenta
que rayita era padrísimo y que realmente
él no hacía nada conforme fui creciendo
me fui dando cuenta que si no tienes
contacto con algo es muy difícil que lo
conozcas para empezar o que lo quieras
mucho menos que lo cuides
entonces críe el concepto granja
didáctica hice la granja didáctica don
pepe y el centro informativo ecológico
lobo para acercar la naturaleza con las
personas hoy no es la excepción pero lo
voy a hacer de una forma diferente hoy
yo quiero hacer la voz de unos
animalitos que son muy importantes en la
vida de nuestro planeta si yo te dijera
si tú pudieras ser la voz de un animal
cuál escogerías estoy segura que me
dirías león tigre lobo caballo águila el
animal que yo escogí es mucho más
pequeño tal vez estás pensando en las
abejas o en las hormigas que son muy
importantes en el equilibrio de la vida
no yo te voy a hablar de unos animalitos
pequeños muy trabajadores
poderosos que son las lombrices
comúnmente llamadas lombrices de tierra
como les voy a prestar mi voz pienso que
la primera pregunta que las lombrices
nos harían ya quizás y algunas
porque no nos quieren bueno yo
si te pido que cierres los ojos y te
imagines una lombriz y me digas la
primera palabra que viene a tu mente
estoy casi segura que me dirías succi
guácala
asquerosa fea larguirucha viscosa pero
sabrosa siempre me dicen mis cosas pero
sabroso
este tipo de adjetivos hace que volvemos
a las lombrices y que realmente no nos
acerquemos a ellas porque pensamos que
son de esta forma aunque hay mucha gente
que cuida actualmente la gran parte de
las personas no las quieren y como no
las quieren no se quieren acercar lo
cual es increíble porque en la
antigüedad
imagínate que aristóteles pensaba que
ellas eran los intestinos de la tierra
él no estaba muy alejado de la realidad
como llegaron a esas conclusiones no
tengo idea
en la época de cleopatra las personas
veían que en los suelos donde había
lombrices las cosechas eran abundantes
fuertes nutritivas lo cual les
garantizaba alimento por lo cual
veneraban a las lombrices las lombrices
eran sagradas para ellos y castigaban
con la muerte a las personas que las
maltrataban o que las cortaban yo
conozco mucha gente y no les quiero
preguntar si tuve alguna pasión en tu
vida se te ocurrió partir a la lombriz
para ver si se movían si por ahí hoy
pues si hubieras estado en la época
agropatria cuello te hubieran dado
porque veían que eran tan importantes
que había que protegerlas
en qué momentos se nos olvidó en qué
momento nos separamos de ellas no tengo
idea y así como las lombrices muchos
ciclos en la vida de nuestro planeta
entonces creo que las lombrices nos
dirían bueno ok si soy tan buena porque
no me valoran te voy a explicar qué es
lo que hacen las lombrices las lombrices
en el lugar donde viven sustratos donde
viven se van desplazando y van haciendo
túneles esos túneles permiten aire y es
que pasa el aire y el agua aireando la
la tierra normalmente le decimos tierra
pero en realidad
el nombre normal debe ser suelo tierra
es el lugar donde vivimos es nuestro
planeta suelo es lo que pisamos entonces
las lombrices están en el suelo conforme
van avanzando ellas van comiendo la
materia orgánica que se encuentran la
digieren en ese proceso digestivo matan
a los microorganismos desdoblan los
nutrientes de la materia que ellas
ingieren y al hacer poco literalmente
esos nutrientes salen y regresan al
suelo enriqueciendo lo
esto es vital porque el suelo es el
alimento de las plantas y de los árboles
lo cual forma parte de la cadena
alimenticia de todos pero además las
plantas y los árboles forman parte del
ciclo del agua y también forman parte
del intercambio de oxígeno y bióxido de
carbono te imaginas qué importante son
el suelo es un recurso finito quiere
decir que se puede acabar y con las
técnicas de siembra que tenemos
actualmente y sobre todo penosamente en
nuestro país estamos realmente dañando
el suelo de una forma que puede ser
irreversible entonces si nosotros
podemos ayudarle a la naturaleza a
recuperar estos ciclos pues vamos a
ayudar a recuperar los suelos
entonces creo que las lombrices nos
dirían bueno pues si somos tan buenas si
trabajamos tanto porque no nos cuidan
lo cual sería obvio que ellas nos
preguntarán eso yo les diría a las
lombrices creo que es por
desconocimiento aunque mucha gente
actualmente sí cuida a las niñas yo soy
una de ellas y a mí me gusta platicar
con las personas para que las vuelvan a
valorar y las cuiden
hay mucha gente que no las cuida ahora
yo les digo las niñas de cariño pero en
realidad esto está mal dicho porque las
niñas ahora sí que no son niñas nuestros
niños son hermafroditas qué quiere decir
que tienen los dos sexos en un mismo
cuerpo son hembra y macho al mismo
tiempo ok
aquí está esta lombriz y no sé si
alcanzan a ver esa pulsera que tienen
allí este como collar ese collar se
llama kristel o cuando tienen el click
de lo quiere decir que ya son adultas
esto más o menos es a los 3 meses de
edad hay muchísimas variedades de
lombrices en el mundo y variant un poco
los calendarios digamos que para
normalizar a los 3 meses de edad ya
tienen el twittero y ya son adultas
entonces ya se pueden aparearse cómo le
hacen pues se juntan dos lombrices
muchas veces me preguntan lo que se
pueden auto fecundar no no se pueden
auto fecundar ellas requieren acoplarse
se engancha la parte femenina de uno con
la parte masculina del otro y al revés y
lo que hacen es un intercambio genético
de adn esto da origen a la nueva
generación
[Música]
esferas que ven aquí se llaman
en estos se van a formar los
bebés lombrices y se pueden ver
perfectamente estos a ver si
puedo sacar este que tengo aquí ya listo
pero es muy chiquito
igual el ratito si quieren pasar a verlo
es éste espera no quiero que se me vaya
a caer vaina que aquí se la voy a poner
para que la sal ok
en estos se forman de 4 a 20
crías en cada con imagínate que se
acoplaron las dos nombres y cada una va
a poner un co con cada semana cada
semana va a estar a parear nos esto es
como un ganado si fueran borregos sería
maravilloso pero bueno estos bebés
lombrices van a tardar se veintiún días
en formarse dentro del pueblo cuando ya
están todos estos bebés lombrices se
abre el cocón y estos bebés son
idénticos a sus papás pero mucho más
pequeños ellos nacen de color blanco y
conforme van creciendo se van haciendo
rosas o cafés hasta llegar a su
coloración rojiza aquí las van a ver
aquí tenemos un grupo de niñas
estas niñas son bastante jóvenes no sé
si alcanzan a apreciar que todavía no
tienen el criterio es increíble que se
reproduzcan de esta manera porque ellas
trabajan toneladas de residuos orgánicos
en el lugar donde viven te imaginas si
el día de hoy aquí en aguas juntamos una
enorme montaña de todas las obras de
todos los alimentos que se han preparado
el día de hoy damas calientes
qué harías con ella para desaparecerla
si la dejamos así se pudre y va a
generar gases y va a generar fauna
nociva va a generar moscas cucarachas
ratas y este ciclo no se va a poder
llevar a cabo si me dijeras bueno pues
vamos a quemarla yo no sé de qué tamaño
series en montaña creo que sería enorme
si la quemamos contaminamos y entramos
nuevamente al calentamiento global me
podrías decir ok vamos a enterrarla muy
bien si la enterramos si se puede hacer
este proceso pero se va a tardar mucho
en cambio si traes un ejército de
lombrices ellas van a poder procesarla y
hacer el ciclo que te platiqué
enriqueciendo el suelo ahora
creo que ellas nos dirían ok si somos
tan buenas
si trabajamos tanto en algún momento van
a volver a querer nos van a volver a
valorarnos a protegernos
yo quisiera pensar que sí
cuando las personas podemos analizar los
problemas que tenemos entonces podemos
encontrar soluciones
un gran y enorme problema que existe
actualmente es el manejo de los residuos
sólidos los residuos son responsabilidad
de cada uno conozco una escuela que no
tiene botes de basura y cuando la gente
dice como que no tiene botes de basura
hay que comprarles botes pues no es que
ellos no generan residuos cada quien se
lleva a sus residuos y se hacen
responsable de ellos esta escuela cuando
los niños salen al patio salen a jugar
salen con su lonchera y cuando toque el
timbre se levantan estos niños se van a
sus clases y hagan de cuenta que nadie
salió al patio lo cual es increíble no
ves un solo papel tirado no es la
escuela más limpia las que más barro es
la que menos se ensucia y esta escuela
tiene un sistema de reciclaje donde
ellos
se regresan esta basura a su casa en la
casa la separan perfectamente regresan
estos residuos separados a la escuela la
escuela tiene unos contenedores por la
parte de afuera donde guardan todo el pp
el vidrio el aluminio etcétera y una
fundación regresa por este material
ve cuánto cuánto juntaron de pan se
juntaron de aluminio etcétera le dan un
valor porque todo este material se va al
reciclaje y con este dinero que la
escuela donó en reciclaje se va a una
fábrica de sillas de ruedas y esta
fábrica dona las sillas de ruedas a
personas que no tienen recursos para
comprar las sillas de ruedas
esto es lo que es sustentabilidad poder
hacer que tus residuos los manejes
adecuadamente les saques provecho los
recicles te den dinero y hagas una labor
social entonces
normalmente en nuestra casa vamos a
hacer limpieza hacemos nuestra casa
preciosa la dejamos linda unas bolsas de
basura enormes al camión
se acabó el problema tú ya te decidiste
de la basura que tenías en tu casa te
pregunto realmente te des hiciste del
problema sólo lo cambiaste del lugar
el estar contaminando el entorno nos
afecta a todos entonces
qué sería lo ideal que efectivamente en
tu casa separes los residuos que se
pueden reciclar y tu materia orgánica
las obras de tu cocina las pongas de tu
nombre y compost te animarías a tener
una lombriz composta
me gusta ver que muchos dicen que sí me
encanta la idea cinco pasos necesitas
sencillo es muy sencillo un nombre y
compostero que es cualquier recipiente
grande de preferencia de boca ancha no
de metal porque se puede oxidar donde le
hagas unos ojitos para que el exceso de
agua drene porque las niñas se pueden
ahogar en un exceso de agua suelo tu
sustrato este sustrato puede ser un
suelo mezclado con abono de herbívoros
no carnívoros los carnívoros presentan
enfermedades parecidas a las nuestras no
es correcto trabajar con ellos por
nosotros no por las niñas entonces
tienes tu suelo tienes a tus niñas y vas
a hacer
lasaña de lombrices literalmente pones
10 centímetros de tu suelo y un poco de
tus niñas 5 centímetros de tu suelo y un
poco de tus niñas así hasta que llegues
casi arriba de tu contenedor
una vez que hagas eso lo mereces
de tal forma que veas que el exceso de
agua drena por los objetos que le
hiciste para mantenerle la templada
humedad a estas niñas ya están
instaladas ahora vas a juntar las obras
de tu cocina que puedes meter casi todo
que no puedes ponerle a las niñas ahí te
va cítricos ajos grasa y comida muy
condimentada bueno y el abono de los
carnívoros no se te olvide tú vas a
tomar tus residuos y tus obras vas a
abrir el sustrato lo vas a poner como a
la mitad metes el sustrato lo tapas y
dejas que tus niñas trabajen una vez a
la semana
vas a voltear con un viento o trinche se
han visto los trinches como de jardín
para hacer que el sustrato de abajo pase
a la parte de arriba a las niñas no les
gusta el sol no les gusta el aire ellas
requieren humedad para hacer
todos sus procesos vitales te digo esto
porque tus niñas van a trabajar en el
fondo del sustrato entonces dónde vas a
tener más nutrientes pues en el fondo
del sustrato lo que tú vas a tratar de
hacer es con el viento pasar la parte de
arriba para abajo
así le vas a ayudar a las niñas a que
esto esté flojo que no se apelmacen y
que ellas puedan seguir trabajando
esto lo vas a hacer sólo una vez por
semana y las sobras de tu comida se las
va a suponer conforme tú las vayas
obteniendo
ahora como puedes saber si tu es el
hombre es que estás haciendo está
enriquecido es muy sencillo que tú comas
alimento muy variado para que tú tengas
muchos minerales muchas vitaminas y
todos estos nutrientes se le regresen a
tu lombricomposta ese humus lo vas a
poder ocupar en tus macetas en sus
cultivos en tus árboles en tu pasto en
donde quieras volver a regresar
nutrientes para las plantas y los
árboles
y nuevamente lo que tienes que hacer es
tapar a tu nombre y composta con una
malla mosquitero para que no se metan
bichos porque a todos los bichos les
gusta la lombricomposta poner una tapa y
mantenerla trabajando continuamente como
puedes saber que estás haciendo un buen
trabajo muy sencillo con tu atención con
tus cuidados y con tu amor vas a poder
tener muchos bebés lombrices y muchos
trabajando para ti me dio
muchísimo gusto platicar con ustedes me
despido mi nombre es socorro iturbe
[Aplausos]
[Música]